I'm not sure you believe me even if I
told you but that shit's happening bad
people are going take down the city
people are going to get hurt you want a
pill today I have an idea while you put
on occasional run around New York at the
end of the second season is that what
matters kind of lost he's given up being
a superhero Matthew this other life
you've had it's your heart still with it
but deep down he genuinely believes the
city is better on with him
you have interrupted a citywide
investigation Jessica's never wanted to
be involved someone say the city doesn't
care Jessica Jones who the hell are you
My name is Matthew Murdock I mean
returning agents out of prison and he's
just trying to figure out what's gonna
do with his life right now that's what
helped people I think there's somebody
you need to meet everything needs them
back to New York who you who you are I
need more time you were now the very
existence of New York is at stake the
four of us are apart to the same place
Midland sir Murdoch
you look like an [ __ ] your score
come are you clear on that an ancient
criminal organization whose goal is
ultimate power I can't be a part of this
if you ask me you already are these
people are incredibly dangerous they're
incredibly evil it's clear to them that
the only chance they have of saving New
York is going to be if they work
together you for the devil of Hell's
Kitchen the smartass detective the
righteous X Cohen and the kid with a
glowing fish in all four of these
characters together is epic
thus for coming together will be
thrilling for fans of all the shows it's
absortion it tells also we communally
turn our back to just try and like take
care of ourselves but it's not about us
that would be a hero is a cubicle runs
from the fire and that people run into
it
junk the city
you'll get used to watching them tall I
fear their horns
[Music]
you